hello to dispositor gellick deputy prime
minister of serbia minister of science
many open questions today in Davos I
pick one and that's to recognize that
over the last two decades the growth of
trade and the increase of investments in
particular towards emerging countries
have been very important factors in
promoting democracy social cohesion and
also taking large numbers of people out
of poverty that's something that
happened too large between Serbia as
well of course starting from a low base
and definitely looking at to the
situation today the question is raised
whether I can continue trading and we
can continue having this engine of
investment today and in the past two
days we have heard from leaders of the
major countries many ideas of how to
take us out of this difficult spot it's
heartening to hear leaders of Europe
leaders of FIFA India leaders of Russia
China and many other countries saying
that they are ready to do their part to
promote economic growth but the question
is raised how are we going to be able to
promote social cohesion and a degree of
strengthening of the institution
democracy with a smaller pie of
investments and shouldn't we avoid being
trapped into a zero-sum game of
everybody trying to outdo or to
out-compete or to dump in particular
socially on the neighbor we believe and
I'll tell you from the vantage point of
emergent Europe that the solution is
possible as long as the big blocks that
have appeared of the last decade work
together to make sure that there is no
movement protectionism to make sure that
the Doha round is closed at the end of
the day and above all to make sure that
we find win-win solutions the idea is
not to close factories in Germany to
open them in emergent Europe or to do
the same thing in other countries so
more consumption in China you know other
emerging nations and then making sure
that we continue trading together
one of the more important things where
we need to provide mobility but also to
find a common agreement is on talents
the demographic situation in the world
he such that rich countries need young
people and the one type of young people
they need most is educated people but
even large countries end up absorbing
entire swathes of elites from emerging
countries there will be no development
in those countries in the end of the day
not enough consumptions to support the
rich ones so let's make sure that in the
forthcoming war on talent we also find a
common language the way that we need to
finance in trade and investment there
should not be worned talent there should
be cooperation to make sure that the
apportion of talent is done the proper
way all around the world everybody would
be better off that way and that's the
message comes from pockets Lee